The Sopranos created a world where
audiences were willing to watch
anti-heroes they did that through the
character of Tony Soprano a mob boss who
was a brutal murderer but also a family
man that also built up the show series
finale to massive levels of hype part of
the audience wanted to see Tony Soprano
pay for his crimes while part of it
wanted to see him get away with
everything
so how David chase ended the show with
the last scene is legendary Tony goes to
a diner to have dinner with his family
then some believe he is murdered while
others think not David Chase just came
out and said in a Fox interview that
Tony Soprano didn't die but he wanted
audiences to be unsure I think David
chases admission is not going to quell
this debate people will be debating
about it until the end of time here's
how he provoked that debate in the first
place we see a shot of his face and then
we see a shot of his point of view and
this continues throughout as he greets
his various family members and the last
shot is him looking up to see his
daughter come in and we never see his
daughter come in we just cut to black
and the people who believe that he died
say that this argues that he was shot in
the back of the head that this guy
coming in right in front of his son AJ
is the guy who kills him the guy in the
Members Only jacket he's somebody we've
never seen before but in the line of
Tony's work you know anybody could die
at any time
onion rings here we have his daughter
doing parallel parking so the idea is
that David Chase is ramping up the
suspense here so much you expect
something to happen but the argument for
the idea that this is more ambiguous is
that David Chase is specifically setting
us up to have this reaction to feel this
tense and then never have that resolved
David Chase loved to do stories that
featured dream logic that were more
about psychology than plotting and
that's one of the things that made the
show revolutionary was it refused to
conform to traditional narrative
structures and having the show and
without a real ending would be very in
keeping with that
one of the arguments I've always liked
about this is that Tony's spirit is
already sort of morally dead we know
that he can't evolve we know that he
can't change as a person and whether he
dies at the end of this scene or he dies
30 years later of a heart attack or he
dies getting hit by a bus crossing the
street he's still dead because he can't
change
you